what is it about being a mobster you
guys seem to operate with the assumption
that the rules don't apply to you you
guys can do whatever the [__] you want
I've never categorized myself as a
mobster oh but you come from that family
my father he catalyzed himself as a
monster at a very normal home matter of
fact after his demise they rest in peace
that's when they got crazy
no with the Columbus crime family
everyone knows right
I'd rather be associated with the yogurt
I'm into probiotics
because of course you were born where I
was born here yes my father was born
here too
never forget we was on the Dick Cavett
Show you know and I think it was uh
1970-71
Kevin paid all this money in practice to
talk to him in Italian when he came out
he told them if he said I don't speak
Italian
well my father was very very uh
aware of his ethnic group and the way he
portrayed himself
so that that whole look or whatever was
not desirable what was your what are
your memories of your dad uh the
greatest moment in the world at the best
nine years a person could have it hasn't
been in very good since
and in our home we got unconditional
love you knew the rules
nobody broke them uh
he was the most advanced human being I
ever met in this thinking process
get the guy could command the boardroom
or talk to a uh a person down on their
luck and he treated them equally
you know he was very respect oriented
and uh
magic about him was you felt safe with
him trusted him his word was everything
and you know he was serious
nobody had a good sense of humor
Integrity yeah very good very good
how did that rub off on you as a Young
Man
I developed a sense of humor because
people saw the size of me the name of me
and they were intimidated by me so I
always said laugh there's medicine for
the soul and uh you know there were a
lot of hardships in my life
uh not that I complained there's been no
poor people have had worse but uh we've
always found laughter I came from a very
happy household you know where most
people would get dramatic or whatever we
would make a joke and get through it but
you lost your dad early
uh my dad
was assassinated in 1971 June 28th but
it took him seven years to die
after seven years old won't you
how old were you and this all I was nine
and I was 16 when he passed they passed
did you want to follow in his footsteps
or in his line of work he absolutely
forbid that kind of activity
absolutely forbid it
you have brothers right
my father whatever came out of that
semicomatostane my brother sort of had a
problem while my brother yes
and whatever course of action my life
took was because of their reactions
they got involved
I don't think they got involved in 85
they got invited on a mass of Rico
and every male member of my family was
in jail and they wanted to put me in
jail but I was just in college
and they had one count against me when
they couldn't get a second for a RICO so
I was the only male member of my family
that was home
so I had three wives
11 children and a mother and sister that
I had to look after
or be the would you call the character
the male role model
that was the most difficult time in my
life I would have rather been in jail
so I noticed like when you're affected
by people who go to jail and when you do
go to jail
done any time yes sure you have so so
tell me what kind of things you got into
I went to I went to jail for making a TV
show making fun of the court system for
what they did to me that's bad acting
pal most people get Emmys I got time
but you got involved in gambling
yeah
I love gambling
I mean who doesn't yeah you know it's
Vice today is Commerce tomorrow
and it's significant because I tell you
why they didn't have the knowledge to
take legalized gambling because it's not
a place where the book could win you
know I learned that you know I went
bankrupt three times being a bookmaker
and I took the action
and the world of knowledge you learn on
the other side of it about gambling is
significant and that's what I'm happy to
talk about now because you just have to
whisper at it because gambling was
controlled by wire rooms you had to know
somebody there was a code it was illegal
so you never openly talked about I mean
you can celebrate you watch the game but
people wouldn't even tell you they bet
on the games
so uh when you're on the other side of
it you learn a lot
and I see that they legalized it my son
wants to tell me about gambling and this
and that so part of what I'm doing is I
always believe some of the bad things
and the good things have gone through
we're trying to share with the young
people that say this younger generation
I just lost contact with them it's not
the younger generation they say it with
music You Know music is just a an
expression of what people are going
through rap it's just basically what
people see and feel and they put it into
music that's what artists do
what you do
so I've never gone along with that
because I used to watch my father was
very significant he would spend hours
with younger people and he could open a
camp for two thousand under privileged
kids he was always for the underdog so I
liked about him there's always 50
Italian people because they don't stick
together any other ethnic group will
come we'll protest
Italians have that jealousy for what was
instilled in us from the other country
to hear from towns against towns to our
color of our skin Northern Italians that
Mike Central Italians didn't like
Southern Italians cocky eyes were in
your hand my mother was green eyed
blonde hair my father was dark guys okay
so we learned to overcome that and he
liked to overcome that and that was his
interest to be Italian American Civil
Rights league and all that story of him
is is amazing in our book itself
uh I probably could tell it now because
most of the contemporaries are gone
and never want to hurt anybody and what
I say but his his story would make the
Godfather look like it's sitting still
really that was truly remarkable
what do you remember most about your
your dad
well I was possible
when he was around it was very good time
in his life
so my oldest brother was 18 years older
than me my next oldest was almost 17. my
brother Vincent who was the only one
that's still alive is 11 and I had a
younger sister and he kept trying he had
and there was a couple miscarriages in
between about 11 years he wanted a
daughter very much
and my sister's a baby she probably
don't want to feel the worser because
we're all infected on that day
memories of my father was and he was uh
we had a very good relationship
he had a way of communicating with
people
unbelievable the things that he said to
me at five six seven and eight nine have
still affected my life and I was still
the ethics morals and philosophies ages
to this day
any bum can take a life only a king
could save one
remember I'm saying that frequently when
you don't know where you're going any
road will get you there
and uh things like that you remember
significantly
you know he was emphatic about his word
and so am I if you give your word you
keep it
you know
there was nothing fake about the guy
what's your sword is what you got it was
an opportunist uh another philosophy
which I still used to do today and
believe in I don't earn money or if
people earn it with them
so it was a very fair time with him you
know it could be considered like Camelot
when did you kind of realize that he was
the head of the Colombo crime family
well you never realized he was the head
of global crime family because a man
should never saw a gun in curse I mean
when he got mad if he yelled he didn't
get so mad if he got yelled when he
looked at you with those eyes same thing
with my kids if I'm screaming I'm
yelling they laugh at me by the time I
got to talk to you they get you know
nervous
you know when you wake up in the morning
and uh and uh
you know uh Nelson Rockefellers in your
living room Frank Sinatra the following
Sunday uh uh Frankie Valley uh Mario
Biagi
uh Maya Kahani you know he he also
believed in the plight of other ethnic
groups now they
organized crime his only organized crime
because the government depicts it
every nationality that interacts with
each other is now labeled of some form
of organized crime I mean if you're
going to do numbers and you're an
Italian neighborhood
you're that Mafia is a is is a term that
the government has stigmatized
of the Italian people in Hollywood too
I'll explain to why they gave it that
name to embed it the Columbo crime
family is still being used today because
it's a branded name it gives them what
they want overzealous prosecutors want
to make a name actually if you're a
hunter you're going for the 11 point
buck even if somebody pasted it there or
you want to put it in the picture you
follow me
so Mafia was uh in Italian I don't know
how to say it I can't play it it's an
abbreviation for it means get the French
out of our country this is a great
organization
Sicily where the name Mafia came from
was probably the most invaded country
because geographically from the Roman
Empire it was the the foothold into
Europe
so France invaded
Sicily the men fled to the mountains
and they were raping the women pilfiger
whatever they wanted you know sacking
the country
so this was an organization a great
organization to come down and they would
kill those that they wouldn't flee back
to the mountains
and how they learned to devise because
you couldn't tell the difference between
the French
and uh and the Italians and the way that
it's written in history and the legend
grows we
we have a being to because
the French could only say Geiger the
Congo because of the different dialect
so the Italians could pretend
to speak French but the French so they'd
asked them and they said they would kill
them and flee back to the mountains
or when they were infiltrated that was a
great organization that was practiced in
Europe not here
it was a purpose for it here uh
policy taking numbers
organized crime Italians this that
there's been actually that that's a
homegrown business from Harlem
that's where it existed in Dutch Schultz
tried to take it away from uh the the
black people it wasn't very successful
but they merged with Italians and they
started a lot of numbers because the
neighborhoods are very close
and that's the whole story of bumpy
Jackson was not too much else is told to
me is true about us anyway
and uh one of the reasons I'm doing this
podcast is to tell the truth
you know people like to hear what they
want to hear I mean
Joe Colombo was a a you know was a war
hero when he came home you know you're
broke you know it was uh there was he
was born in a recession
and uh I I believe that his Empire was
built on gambling and so was mine but
for me it happened by accident him if I
had desire and
book making necessity bookmaking what's
that bookmaking
well at that time policy was big
bookmaking could become as big until
football kicked in but there was
baseball and stuff like that people bet
about just on anything
my aunt my landscape actually invented
it
and he was kind of by accident the
person that taught me about it that's
how I learned to have a mind is
everything and uh you know things you
wouldn't know and then when you get in
there you learn them the hard way
because
you know you do have a shot to beat the
bookmaker a very good one money
management self-control on the line is
the whole game
you know it types people which is fun to
hit these ballets but that's just
another way to take 46 cents out of your
pocket to hit for a million six hundred
thousand has people done that one
but you know how much money there was
chasing that
so the thing now about sports that you
can bet from 50 cents up to 50 million
so part of the things I'd like to do is
I believe in betting on sports I believe
in betting on anything because you know
Gamble's a good people
when they lose they say what did I do to
deserve this you know but you got to try
to keep the the the addictive
personality in gene at Bay and people
can understand that and the good thing
about it when it was illegal there was a
lot of people with that addictive gene
as in drugs they probably wouldn't do it
or with the bits and the Bounty of the
church
um we know the church has dropped the
ball like nine so we're kind of in a
Lost Generation family units broken down
the church has dropped the ball and part
of what I do is you know I've seen the
worst of life
and maybe I could avoid a few people not
do that or save some children so I have
a son and a daughter which I love very
much
so you got into gambling what you got
into gambling by accident how did that
happen
I early on I had a young friend
and he says he had a bar we used to hang
out in and he says and he needed a hook
to get into gambling to be a bookmaker
because if you didn't have an office and
know how to work in office and how to
move it around in a wire room and move
the lines and have clerks and all that
and know how to do the work which is
significant before computers and
correlate that work and put it into a
logical Ledger
you have to have it in so I'd say like
yourself you say I want to bet you meet
somebody you get a code you would call
the office and you would say but you can
use real names like uh
celebrity photographer for my code was
ghosted because they're always looking
to catch me somewhere but they couldn't
so they nicknamed me the ghost
and then later on they said that was The
Wizard because I got so good so I had a
website called uh wizardsports.com but
it was a little you know I'm infatuated
it was
Maryland Camelot stuff like that I love
history
so anyway uh you would now become a
runner if you had players
so this is how you expanded your
business let's say you had five friends
the bat but you would come in but start
with a quarter sheet 25 as you build up
it would go all the way to 50 percent
so let's use a 50 50 sheet from for
example your guys are calling for a code
for you but you know not even an office
works so the bet you're gonna get is a
50 sheet so let's say the overall figure
for your players is they won ten
thousand the office would pay you and
meet you the ten thousand you would pay
your players you're now in the red for
ten thousand means you owe that ten back
they lose 20 you get 10 back to the
office you keep five they keep five
so this guy was at the position he told
me he had a lot of players
but he didn't know what to do with them
and the people in his bar and he needed
someone he could trust so I said no
problem I go down and plus uh he was a
golf kid really nice person at that
point gambling got the best of them
and this is how I got into bookmaking
and uh his his
Butler was my media reader another young
kid and both of them were like scratch
golfers athletes like the drink and they
come to the spa to do what they did
so I go to an office and he says to me
uh
someone prefer a half sheet this is how
many players I said I don't know yet but
we don't normally give them out he said
you're Joey's son I said she Aces give
me whatever he wants
so
first week about eight or nine players
come in and this is significant money
because I believe it's a 19
in the 80s early 80s like 80 81.
I was young the drinking age was 18 so I
might have just turned 18 or been 17.
so they went forty thousand dollars
which is money in 1979 and 80.
they wouldn't deal with that might pick
up the 40 000 and I'll just do it as a
friend that was working in the Bronx at
the time
and the officers in Queens and I would
meet them somewhere in Manhattan and I
would meet them somewhere in between I'd
bring them to forty thousand they're not
forty thousand in the red
next week they win 26 000 between all
their plays I'll pick up the 26 to get a
club the next week they lose over ninety
thousand so I figured they made a few
thousand twelve or thirteen thousand it
was somebody told us they'd put back I
can't find nobody
oh [__] I says I'm on the hook for this
money
so I never forget it was a
border car for my nephew his father was
in jail there was a stick shift the guy
on the 280ZX
and that was the only car I had
available because I picked it up that
day and it was really good with stick
shifts so I go to the guy's girlfriend's
house and I park but I don't put a
parking but I actually saved it for me
snapping his spout
I brought you all this money I bought
you uh
uh 67 000 or whatever it is I says
where's their money he said oh she's a
big guy so it's just supposed to work on
his pouch it's a week overdue
this is in the middle of this thing
well anyway
uh the car starts rolling back was I
have to run out and Chase it he
disappears I finally tracked him down
and he's sitting in his basement he says
one of these bowling cap guns that you
load kind of thing he says he's going to
kill himself
uh some of the players are true but the
ones that wanted the real ones and the
rest I bet
it's like oh I meet the office he says
uh you know where's the money and says
listen
in a situation
I said gambled
this is uh actually I took the brunt
because I think he was a little bit of
trouble
and that's not my way to get people up
so it's uh
sorry what do you want to do he says you
want to make a settlement I said no you
got every dollar because we're gambling
as long as it's whatever they've been
looking to just get their money back
they gave me and then when it was
entitled people chop or whatever I says
uh I wouldn't do that to you and it's
all right he says you want to keep it
going I told him he says yeah
you did it again
now I'm on a hook for big money and he
was good for a while and he was making
money so I said listen
our partners I says let's work this out
and I never looked back
because I went to the point where I
built up customers I got good at it I
started enjoying it and I was more
careful because it came from a bad
experience and that's how it happened
you learned your lesson early yes you
started making money you started making
money
okay
what do you consider money
it's an amount but let's let's because
the government alleged over a 30-year
period I averaged net net triple met uh
70 000 a day throughout my career
I would have to say in their fantasy of
the 70 if it was a real fantasy it would
be more like 200 200 000 a day what 200
000 a day
uh seven days a week
betting on sports
horses fights
presidential election I even put a line
out on my sentencing and Under and Over
really yeah you know where your friends
were there they bet more time and less
time on whatever the demand I put out
and there was a two-year Under and Over
is there an addictive thing about about
all that
there's people that have the addictive
personality could destroy them and
that's part of what the podcast is and
how to deal with that that's why I never
had any trouble or any violence man they
alleged a lot of violence which did not
exist
actually what they did a ledge and money
went so crazy on the HBO show is we sat
down to play cards all their victims
were sitting at my table but what the
victims were there for is they were the
gentlemates
not in the bad sense of where you could
pause gambling is the generate gamblers
let me say that with the addictive
personality
and I pushed up and paid their debts I
told people you can't take their vets
anymore
so when it came out on the spend of what
the government did to what actually was
the jury was actually crying
so the biggest part of that business is
let's say you come in and you lose
two million dollars you know you don't
have to be in the pay and I don't know
how they let you do it I ran it like a
corporation like you can only be allowed
to bet what you could pay
uh
by accident let's say you will have
extended your limit it would be our
fault like if I put you on for a week or
two thousand mile limit and in the
office or whatever because we didn't
have computers like that time you get
blown out at the one o'clock games we
didn't know the scores yet didn't have
time to do it and if you doubled your
limit we won't be responsible for the
limit
and at the point that your limit was
there when I lose those bets were gone
because you know what you were doing but
the money you make as a bookmaker when
you're making that kind of money that
becomes an addiction
right you can't put you can't stop that
pretty easily I did earlier when I
walked in you said I would do this for
free
Florida really
listen
right now everybody knows Tom Brady is
the best quarterback that ever lived you
can't go against them and so I think
they're smarter some were better in some
ways whatever but he's definitely the
best
wouldn't you like if you can't be Tom
Brady
and you can't own Tom Brady and he can't
play with Tom Brady wouldn't you want to
bet on Tom Brady
sure Mickey Mantle Derek Jeter you know
right up till today
I mean these people are heroes
in their own right but they're still
people
and is that connection when you bet
you feel they're playing for you
the only thing I love to learn from of
all players because this week I was
rooting for this team the next week I
was moving to the next team depending on
the way people bet I mean
I bled from the Yankees run you follow
me but it was like bittersweet because
secretly in your heart you were rooting
for them you know
they probably cost me more money than
anybody
but I love I love Joe Montana and of
course your fortune in his run and uh
what's his name Steve Young
it was a great team
I mean I love the 85 Bears that in mind
was in that Super Bowl that's a great
team oh they're not here to cause no
trouble they're just here to do the
Super Bowl Shuffle they announced that
the third thing you know Walter Payton
might think it looked like a bear I
think he kept this theme of The Cave
before he let them out you know buddy
Ryan and his defense well he called the
refrigerator
Samurai Mike with those eyes I mean that
was a team that was one incredible year
yeah
but you got in trouble eventually
government because of my name always
wanted to foot me there were things
going on and the climate out there and I
had something they thought I had
something they wanted and they always
portrayed bookmakers because they're not
a violent crime but they were associated
you got thousands of people calling you
ways of getting information so most of
your bookmakers familiar that weren't
from my background we give you up on a
heartbeat so they leaned hard because
they profiled the non-violent crime but
you don't want to give up the money so
they came at me hard very very hard
so I had a Target on my back a lot of
ways most ways because of the climate so
I didn't really grow up when it was a
good time to have the Wasteland Colombo
right
your family name got you in trouble
uh yeah that and probably my big mouth
I say what's on my mind
you never put your head on your pillow
worrying about what I think
sometimes I worry about when I sleep but
you don't have to worry about it
what did you do how much time what's
that how much time did you do actually
the judge they put me they helped me as
a danger and I I got no bail and then I
got strict strict Bale I couldn't even
walk out of my house to grab a cigarette
uh couldn't walk my kids to the bus stop
right in front of the house
uh matter of fact they put him and they
would let me out an hour a day after 18
months I have ever animals peacocks uh
uh llamas all kinds of stuff you know
but my my father's house to Ranch he had
a lot of horses I I have a few but I
have other animals you know cleaning
those stalls as a kid was tough
and we had 52 horses there so uh
the lawyer puts in could clean the pool
chemical the pool but can't swim in the
pool and I never remember getting a
paranoid you think people are watching
you until I'm trying it's like 98
Degrees I'm trying to figure out like
well I'm vacuuming how to fall in uh uh
or or drop something so I had to put my
body here funny I couldn't do it I just
did a swanny off the board if they want
to put me in jail during my bathroom in
the pool yeah
[Music]
yeah
and they're watching your what they're
watching your house the whole time
my case they bugged 27 phones
my uh my house three locations in my
boat and a couple cars
they had a white Captain ran six years
is it a stressful lifestyle to be
wiretapped and watched and suspected all
the time by everyone no but gambling it
was fun most people got violations
because of my name you know you get 10
or 12 violations they come in they
arrest you I mean before they really
started targeting bookmaking uh most of
my clerks who retired firemen and
retired police officers picking up ships
and I was really good with them you know
nobody cared about gambling now
gambling I mean look at me now
so uh
it was actually fun you'd spend a night
in the can they come in hard you know
you go before the judge you've really
shown your Roman Carlos give your bell
and how they put you out of business
after 10 or 12 pictures violations
you've got to misdemeanors after so many
misdemeanors they give you a felony with
no time
that's when you're going to stay out of
the office and be careful but I never
got to that point it all came at once it
was New York state law
second felony mandatory two to four
years
so no bookmaker wants to go to jail you
know I love that so I don't really
didn't care
what's the craziest story you ever had
from all that we don't have enough time
but in what area and I'll tell you
just one guy getting himself in indeed
that's a guy that actually beat my case
for me that they put down as a victim
had a furniture store in the Bronx like
Buy Here Pay Here credit he was the
worst the general Campbell I've ever
seen in my life and
we became friends you want to bet with
me won a lot of money he had one on a
run he destroyed everybody but he never
had a damn lock until that time he made
millions and when he was going bad
everybody thought he had the money he
didn't
so prior to that time he had a very
heavy set mom named Blossom Jewish woman
I loved her
father was a husband his father was an
investment banker the way they had a
white mustangs very particular guy and
this particular guy was just
the craziest gamble I'd ever seen used
to keep his bats in his shoes so he
couldn't find them because we'd Shake
him down looking for to see if he was
betting you know
I had to pay for his daughter's speech
therapy lesson one time he sent his wife
on vacation didn't have enough money to
bring her back
and his Jewish mom would always call me
she says uh
you gotta help Randy So Randy calls me
some a little bit of trouble he says how
much
he says uh is that now I can talk he's
just about the thirty thousand
excite
I says
from the time he got to me
it was over 260 000.
so and his mother's crying and you know
I loved her she was just a nice woman
so we make a sit down in the thing each
bookmaker came in one at a time and I
tell him he says listen
uh
you're not hurting this guy
you don't understand he put us in
trouble he won this much money he went
on a run he was changing the lines he
thought he was genius everything just
happened he lost all that back plus
that's how he got from being about 500 a
game because he was winning they wanted
it back to five and ten thousand game of
multiple people so I believe there was
bookmakers that came in one of the times
so
I ended up
paying out 50 cents on the dollar
with the promise that they never let him
bet again but they took some beating
with him because of the money he won
possibly most had to settle for fifty
percent
they agreed to it we paid it
and I never forget yelling at him can't
you get a hobby can't you do something
by a fish tank uh
other than this
he says I'm going to do that buddy he
says to me
not four days or five days later my
phone starts ringing and people are
cursing me off the hook
you stepped into the sky you paid half
the money well guess what his hobby was
I bought a resource and areas in the
Winner's Circle oh Jesus
and Yonkers
so I call him up and says what did you
do he said I got a pet like you said
it
didn't stop what it didn't stop
a little son Benji I was in the house
and there was an electrical storm and
the lights went out he said that he
didn't pay the electric again
and he made big money
one time I walked into the furniture
store
and he's eating like uh like from one of
these swing places and he's he's
throwing the bones like real these two
guys standing there because they had to
regularly rescue him
and his pretty large guy an amazing guy
standing Maximus says that he found an
ancient bookmaker to betway because I
can't believe this right
yeah it was out of his mind
so
I'm in there so his sister walks in and
she's so used to him there was Secret
Service guys she says the president we
just took him skiing he was cashing
checks he was you have no idea and
didn't care it was about the action
but some people could destroy the
accident and I guess that's part of what
I'm going to try and educate people how
to do give them the inside world to the
other side how to if not win by the end
of the year not blow your whole life
away
what's going through the gambler's mind
when he's thinking
he's already down Thirty thirty thousand
I'll give it to the exactly and then
he's turned he's turned it into doubt
he's now he's down 250 000. well it
depends on the limits you give them you
know there's something going on in his
head that tells him it's going to be
different next time
if a guy has a drinking problem you see
it guys a drug problem you see it
gamblers
you don't see him coming they can wipe
your fortune out like in no time
their family friends whatever and
they're usually very happy-go-lucky
people
uh how I dealt with him was really
simple let me let me just point to you
the degenerate gambles these are guys
that really have problems with because
bookmakers don't want to hurt nobody
they want to make book they like the
action too
so
generally can but if you gave him a
choice to be up 50 000 on a Sunday and
stop
will be up down fifty thousand and bail
out by the end of the night they take
the second choice no matter one every
time
it's the action it's the Fear Factor
it's the pressure the adrenaline yeah
yeah what I used to do with them is they
used to say listen
without
what happens in a vacation not getting
your kids new shoes taking your wife's
not buy anything how much could you
reasonably afford to lose a week they
said 500 I'd say bet 10 000 whatever you
want on every game because they just
want to bet more and more and that's
what they're doing with these Ballers
and stuff like that but anyway
I says and what we'll do is we'll go on
the red and black when you're up I give
you 500 a week to go into red when
you're down you give me 500 a week to go
to the Plus
most of them go back and forth some of
them but owe me when it's over it's over
I didn't want to do it I just didn't
want them to come in win 150 000 and
then lose 30 the next week and have
nothing that's what causes the problem
man with their Runners because they're
responsible on their rent they would
wreak havoc in your business
it's got to be such a stressful way to
go with your life
listen
you meet people you have problems within
your business at times it's just part of
the days
you know I never thought there's
anything wrong with gambling I mean
right now they're advertising it
everywhere and I'm all for it so it's
legal now right but that still doesn't
eliminate the problems that could happen
no all the approach to it that's why I'm
doing it I'm going to educate people how
many gamble how to behave themselves
together again what could happen so are
you still doing what you used to do but
you're doing it legally now
no you really can't because they pick
and choose who they want
and it's done by computers you got to
remember we didn't take a thousand
different propositional bets and
everything because it wasn't time to
call it out change the lines do it by
Clerk and even remember computers when
you did that computer cannot accurately
assess a line
so there are spots that I can teach
people to if they want to listen so
you're teaching people how to gamble yes
intelligently yes
I've learned that
you think there's a way to fix a gambler
a degenerate gambler
it's like any other addiction you can't
fix it until they want to fix themselves
but usually that degenerative gamble
will go into another addiction it's the
addictive personality it's not the
gambling to addictive person I've seen
them again it's a new drug comes out
Crack we got to destroy that you don't
hear much about it now whatever the new
drug is the addicted personality is
going to go to
is it the adrenaline fix or is it just a
self-destructive stuff I don't know
that's why people take Fentanyl the
closer you get to death the same way
with the degenerate Gambler I mean why
would you take something you know as
killing people
all right smoke a pot you know you're
not going to die maybe eat a lot maybe
get paranoid probably maybe can't drive
as good as you could
but you're not going to overdose on it I
don't think I mean it's possible but
it'll be really tough
same thing with the degenerate Gambler
the closer they are to the edge
the better the adrenaline rush is enough
humans are interesting aren't we in
search of I would say yeah I mean some
people are jumping out of airplanes some
people are mountain climbing yes
that's not addictive that's adrenaline
rush me I'm built like a bowling ball I
think I wanted me to fly I would have
gave me wings but I like to scuba tag
like animals you know some people rather
jump out of a plane
nobody talks down there and everything's
beautiful
now but then again I like to quad phase
I like the horseback ride you know it's
a matter of taste
we live in a world where people are
afraid to be themselves they look for an
identity I don't I don't do that
I know who I am you know you see you
said I was a character I am you know I
enjoy characters
how has Society changed over the years
I don't know Society is changing
evolving revolving or going backwards
I think people in this country don't
have an identity of themselves
I think the younger people are even more
difficult and I think that there's no
stability like there was and that's what
I'm trying to replace like
I didn't have my grandparents while my
parents along but if I did it would have
been someone to go to or my children to
go to so I had to be very structured in
what I did
when my father was always all about
structure organization scheduling
how involved did the mafia get in all of
this
kind of the bookmaking and all that
when you say Mafia I'm going to tell you
you know unless you I'm going to ask you
about the being it's not necessary
that's that was a stigma that was given
to
put a name on Italian uh how much an
Italian bookmakers get involved as much
as they did in their entire neighborhood
if other people came from the Polish
enabled people gamble get a Polish
bookmaker
so you know they made it sound like they
controlled it did they have stronger
offices and some people from other areas
or Runners and stuff like that
absolutely
I mean the guy actually syndicated it
was my Lansky
I mean he was probably the most
brilliant guy in the world and by
accident I I spoke with him and
had a very short thing because I think
he died in 83 I think it was like 79 80
81 82.
um
you know I was uh after my father got
hurt uh died I wasn't angry that he died
he was a man
we knew that day it was going to happen
the federal government couldn't tell Pro
division in the FBI he said he became so
powerful these people it won't punch him
back off you people let this thing die
who shot your dad cold tell Pro division
of the FBI really of course that was the
only day in history they were watching
but didn't take film and confiscated all
the film and I could say it now because
he's dead the guy that shot my father
was a friend of my brothers and my
father didn't want no guns around but he
didn't know somebody who pulls the
Steelers while they were handcuffed they
got a shot my father he crawled
underneath emptied the gun and then left
his shoe and then walked the hospital by
my father then we sent them away and the
defense said tell him to come home
that's that's not what made me angry
he made a decision as a man to go to his
debt for his people and I could agree
with that that I like the aftermath of
it I mean could have if I was older
would I have tied him up and held him
there
yeah probably but not talking him out of
doing the right thing was just
completely
an exercise of utility everybody you
talked to say they were three or four
feet away or right there eighty thousand
people tell you that
what it was was the same surgeon that
was standing by
the hospital he took Kennedy to the
closest hospital was Roosevelt Hospital
was Dr Hansen
and what happened was it wasn't semi
comatose it happened there was times and
he fought hard him credit that my whole
our whole life for me 90 to 16 we turned
the whole country house into like a
place to rehabilitate them
and he didn't need life supporting they
need stuff like that so we weren't going
to put them anywhere we took care of
them all of them you know still do
and uh
it's amazing you know he's done a lot of
good and like got even with a lot of bad
too
but I could tell you right now I've
agreed but everything is done
and I don't know if I would have had the
balls to do it
or the Ingenuity or the self-control as
a human being to do it properly
and uh
it was
amazing so anyway
getting to the point we have doctors
coming stuff like that there was times
he was almost himself speak a walk and
there was times he went into this week
there was semicomatos
we waited for the CAT scan to be
developed because at that time they
couldn't actually see what was going in
the brain they would take raise with
x-rays they did the catch me and we
brought a doctor up and it was like I
believe the first CAT scan done to the
to the public
and uh
they never put the shunt in after they
did the brain surgery so the pressure
never relieved they killed him that day
and he fought hard and stuff that was my
Angry ears
so what carried over into what they said
and when I was dangerous I never
bothered anybody but you took a lot of
ribbing at that time ripping him for
what he is kids are cruel
uh people tried to Bull me a lot because
of the name I like shooting Jesse James
and I kind of like the suburban area
wasn't the neighborhood there was no
fear of that or whatever so I missed
that 12 14 flights a day
still to the state I'm probably one of
the best people with their hands on this
planet
but I believe the only control a man has
is self-control the rest is up to God
giving you regrets in your life I never
had a choice in my life so what could
you regret
I do what's right if that has
consequences I accept them
what do you worry about now what do you
fear I have neurological line they gave
me six months to live in 1998 I've had
double hit the place for my hearts and
large I was blind for seven months
to have
couldn't walk confirmed
I had double implications and walked out
of the hospital the third morning after
never saw anything like it
died twice metcard when I died
uh
from the treatments and the from the
Lyme disease just went through a battle
now I had no shot to beep because I
can't take uh the only cure that's known
for it was suffered intravenously
because I built the bad electric shock
from taking it so much
it's a miracle I'm sitting here right
now
Chris what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
forget the experience remember the
lesson people today hold that experience
they can't see what the lesson was
I never sold so so clear well I was
blind
I never realized what it was like to run
until I couldn't walk
everything happens for a reason and
people focus on the experience so that
becomes issues if you remember that
lesson it's for a reason
I believe that my heart
thank you so much for sharing your story
thank you for listening believe me I'm
the one that's appreciative of you it's
fascinating
story you got thank you so much my
pleasure my honor and can I say
something absolutely anybody that plans
to come on the show
if you guys one of the finest gentlemen
one of the most endearing spouse sincere
have no fear
thank you